these animals uh you know they're an
amazing animal they're absolutely
beautiful um
and
they're they're built to do one thing
and that's haunt
that's that's what they do
um and they come with claws and with
teeth and so this isn't the
animal that we have grown up watching on
tv
the killing of a mountain lion found in
the backyard leaves many in the
community asking why now state officials
are responding good evening to you
thanks for joining us at six i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez we have new
information tonight about the mountain
lion that was shot and killed yesterday
in the southwest valley nevada wildlife
stating it was tagged meaning the animal
was in that area before its return has
created some concern over public safety
christian casares joins us live tonight
near el capitan in flamingo where the
animal was finally captured
[Music]
that's right guys well nv wildlife
officials tell me mountain lions are not
uncommon
so far deep in the valley they say as
our drought issue continues we can
expect to see some more of these wild
animals again and again in our
neighborhoods like these searching for
food and water and that is exactly what
officials are concerned about
why did they have to kill him a las
vegas family capturing this video from
inside their home after a mountain lion
was spotted in their backyard after two
shots the game wardens were able to
capture and euthanize the wild animals
that's a difficult choice
that that choice has to be made in the
moment at that place at that time doug
nielsen with the nevada department of
wildlife says mountain lion sightings
are becoming frequent around the valley
because of the drought the goal is to
relocate the animals but it's not always
what happens the animal does have an ear
tag i do not know at this time when that
animal was handled it was probably
sometime in the past couple of years
meaning that it was in the valley
already once before and tranquilized by
us and moved elsewhere and has since
made its way back which shows a
habituation behavior which is not good
for the animal and it's not good for the
public over the last year the state
agency has received about 50 calls about
sightings he says these animals are very
dangerous and aim to relocate the
mountain lion they have public safety
officer safety and then what we can do
for the animal simply trapping or
tranquilizing and moving an animal is
most often unsuccessful monday's
incident involved several attempts to
sedate the big cat but nielsen says it
failed until it was cornered in a
family's backyard if they come and go
we're fine with that it's when they
come and stay and show no desire to
leave
back out here live some advice from envy
wildlife on keeping some of these
animals these wild animals away from
your property they say pick up any food
and feces from your pets keep those
trash bins closed and you might want to
trim some of your landscaping but the
best recommendation they say is never
engaged with these animals because
remember they are dangerous christian
casa is live local now